[Music]
let me tell you right off that I did not
invent this field we've detected
gravitational waves from thus crashing
of two black holes into each other this
is the beginning of a whole new way of
studying the universe it's like gonna do
you sling the telescope for the first
time what is a gravitational wave
it's an excitation of space and time
together nobody really believed that you
could ever detect them because the size
of the effect is so small the idea was
extremely simple what the gravitational
wave does is it stretches space this way
and compresses space that way so you
exploit that property but one object
here and another object over there and
let the gravitational wave go through
that system and it'll change the space
between these by contracting that one
and extending that one and I came the
conclusion that if you made this long
enough kilometer scale you could
probably get these extremely precise
measurements
I said holy mackerel we have shown that
Einstein God knows how he got it was
right in 1915 to me that's a miracle
that that happened man's thinking not
only in the theory but the elegance in
the experiment I mean that is a human
endeavor that I think everybody in the
world should be proud of congratulations
we are thrilled for you I'll go through
for all those who collaborated with you
and guess what you know what I think you
are the best of em I fear a thank you
congratulations